Let's begin with some basic.
Set theory.
because again
the Bayesian theorem depends on conditional probability
and conditional probability.
has to do with
sets
the combination of sets
so let's look at an example. I'm going to
draw two.
Venn diagrams
and in both sets we have elements.
some of these some of these elements
could be common to both of these sets.
So for example
Okay.
Let me grab a screenshot and bring it into markdown.
Okay, so we have these two sets A and B if we were to.
Take the intersection of these two sets we
would get something that looks like this. Of course.
So the elements that are common to both sets are
the elements.
D and E
And as usual, if we were to take the union of
these two sets. Well, then we'll get all the elements.
Okay, so the above it?
is intersection
the one that is below is the Union.
So here we are saying it has to be the elements
that we are looking for must be inside set a
and in set B.
And as you can see, we only have d and e that
is common to both.
in the second example we were saying
Elements that are coming to either one.
and of course
we get all the elements.
We get all the distinct elements.
from a to H
Now let's talk about now. Let's look at an example where instead of
we
having
non-numeric elements in the sets A and
B. Let's look at an example where we have quantities in these
sets.
Then we could produce a table.
where we have
something called the marginals
so we will need to see that we'll have the table containing
the marginals.
And then we'll see how we can translate that table into the
conditional probability. So
we first will go from the table of data.
Two conditional probability once we get an understanding
of what symbols mean
and why certain axioms hold we will
then proceed to derive the basic theorem.
So I'm going to once again.
Reproduce this Venn diagram a little bit differently.
two sets
and this could be sets containing a number of elements.
For example some products and it could be the case that these
two sets have a number of things in common.
If we were taking if we were to take it into
section of these two sets.
and let's say
they have five things in common.
So set a has 65 things set B
has 10.
Common to both of them are five particular
things. So imagine you have two stores. They have
five.
Similar products they both have these five products.
Or this could be a two sets of people.
And these two sets have five people in common.
Let's say set B is a
small family
and set a is a particular company.
And it turns out that five people five family members
of that.
Family work in the same company so the
company and their family have these
five elements in common.
what these quantities are is at the
point the point is
How we use?
How we go from sets?
to
relative frequencies and from there
we can count or we can calculate conditional probabilities
how we get marginal probabilities
and Joint probabilities.
So I'm going to bring this.
diagram into our note
okay, so we have that diagram I
talked about and then we have
we're going to put this data into a table.